The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, which
of the following
is a good and valid definition
for a class representing a car?
OK, most of the people
I think have gotten it,
which is the red, which
says class car object,
and that's perfect.
OK.
So this defines a function,
this defines a class correctly,
but A is just not
descriptive name at all,
and this is kind of weird, and
this is the right one here.